[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys today we have can hey ken
hey hi ken old friend friend of the show
ken hello everyone was like who's that
[ __ ] guy sitting next to joe with a
guitar everybody forgot about me bro
dude but you're back so you gotta let
him know ken he's been around since the
donna time the dawn of time yeah wait
why did people forget you because you're
quiet as [ __ ] yeah i don't i don't say
much
pick up the volume were you the guy with
the guitar like in high school i was
no i wasn't i actually just learned
guitar like last year yeah yeah like two
years ago are you getting good are you
passionate about it you do what i am
passionate about i love it so much where
my fingers i don't feel my fingers are
you doing vietnamese covers yet eric
clapton songs have you done stairway to
heaven vietnamese stuff stairway to
vietnam
no i don't i don't do any of those songs
or blackbird by the beatles do you know
my name from uh this guy named keshie
you guys know who keshie is kesha yeah
yeah no pressure yeah very good artist
yeah i know but yeah i just play those
songs and i just practice going down
[Laughter]
it's the start of something i didn't
clean this very well actually no you did
it
hey grab the guitar let's soundtrack our
conversation a little bit all right so
kim what are you even up to man
he's gonna [ __ ] play a guitar he's
gonna be a vietnamese k-pop star i think
that's where you take the k out i've
been playing synth music he's a vp
sing your answers sing what's your
favorite song hey no no copyrighted
music and [ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] yourself
don't worry about it
do you know mine
you just bailed out that was great we
get edited out you're editing it cut it
out
[Music]
if i saw you in vietnam
definitely your parody
[Music]
that's pretty good though i can't wait
to revisit you in six months you were
kind of in joe's shadow on that one but
you know we'll give it to you can you
how's your how's your windmills bro my
windmills i could do
three hey show us hey show us your
windows [ __ ] dude i'm just gonna do all
come on
don't hit the cages arcade
this whole this whole video is just
going to be doing be doing stuff let's
do cool stuff out of frame yeah let's
see that what else you've been learning
what else you've been learning you know
what though like so i i'm excited can is
like the little brother that i never
wanted that i got but i also don't want
him around right so
we've been around for a long time he was
my roommate and a friend yeah you guys
lived together for a while we met well
i've known you before [ __ ] periodics
somehow you yeah you did you knew me
right when we started like wait how long
did you guys live together for okay so
like
years time bro 2010 we [ __ ] lived
lived for four
with each other and alhambra and then we
[ __ ] lived with each other in
whittier yes what are some of the that's
four years you're right
that's like four years what are these
bad living habits
well he i've i've watched this dude
groan he's watched me groan over the
years so his habits girl are not a
shower huh his his habits are probably
not the same as what they used to be
like leaving [ __ ] dishes in the sink
god damn i did do that i did do that but
everybody does that let's be real we
also want to know what are joe's weird
habits yeah joe's weird habits uh does
that know him though i mean you already
kind of know what he's like it's just
exactly like how he is here but at home
so just every morning no matter what the
[ __ ] is going on and like he's just like
being uncle that's how he wakes up yeah
he's like what the [ __ ] like he'll cuss
every time there's like dishes in this
thing like mother [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
this and then he tosses [ __ ] around
punches holes in the wall same thing
like like here i had a big hole in my
door because i punched it
yeah
what caused that punch in the argument
the dishes oh dude and it wasn't your
door because it was around there's a
hole in the wall from the stairs too
from the your gun safe oh yeah but that
wasn't out of anger that was out of
six asian guys not being able to lift
the gun safe to the second story and
then they [ __ ] bumped it against the
wall when that happens and then he got
angry from that and he punched a hole in
the wall afterwards
my landlord loved us so much though
because at first he was like oh i don't
know man like a bunch of [ __ ]
roommates young people you guys gonna
[ __ ] it up and at the end he loved us so
much because we improved it i [ __ ]
put money in to improve the backyard
like we put palm trees in that [ __ ]
we [ __ ] made we didn't leave the
place that much better we left it with
holes but he gave us a hundred percent
of the [ __ ] deposit oh that's nice
which which house did you like more the
first house we stayed in or the second
house the second house second house me
too that was because the first house was
owned by uh my ex's family and that's
why what's the craziest [ __ ] you ever
seen joe do in the house [ __ ] run around
with his hands taped together like this
why are we doing that
i have no idea what was that was it a
sex related incident it might have been
i didn't ask questions he was like in
the middle of a thing and you went to
get water yeah i didn't ask questions
did he still have the plug in his butt
that time was he like
penguin or no i i'm not sure but that
was like one of the moments where i was
like huh this is what it's like living
with joe
it was it was super random i was like
why is he taped up you know what i'm not
even gonna ask i i bet i know why it
wasn't anything sexual i bet it was
something like joe had a wild thought in
his head he was sitting down he goes i
wonder if i could handcuff myself with
some tape i wonder if i can break out of
it it sounds like a bart move now i feel
like that's some [ __ ] joe would do and
just like i wonder what my day would be
like if i was just handcuffed off you
know what my favorite memory is working
on music with you that was fun right
like we used to do a lot of creative
[ __ ] all the time hey play one of your
songs play with your songs one of you
and joe's original we made two albums
together you guys did yeah because
i played the keys or like instruments
and then like or i would compose with
ken and i would come up with melodies in
my head or sometimes i would hum
something out and then he would [ __ ]
like play it and come like he would be
like what do you like arrange it yeah
yeah i would pretty much produce it yeah
you really you really got nothing on
your phones now i'm actually genuinely
curious what about spotify there's stuff
on youtube
we have two
we had a house production crew not a
house but like house music
called the dusky hunters oh yeah dusky
hunter yeah yeah this is this is
something that we both made
this is called asteroids you only get 10
seconds otherwise copper yeah
[Music]
get get them in the middle and then you
know what our our company is going to
copyright this video right now doesn't
matter if we talk over it you know it's
not going to read it
that's the build up give them the good
stuff nah i want to hear the drop dude
over here the drop this isn't the good
[ __ ] right here over here it's coming
it's coming you can tell you gotta
hit the peep ken
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
all right i'm trying to be like anthony
dude
hey that's kind of hey that's actually
really good but anyway that's why did
you guys stop uh because we got busy
he got busy i got busy and then that's
the funnest part about like living with
can though this dude is probably one of
the most talented [ __ ] i've
ever met wow no offense to you guys but
this is because
you guys are all talented in your own
way okay but this dude
he's the kind of guy that when he has an
interest he goes balls to the [ __ ]
walls
and then he goes to this point of like
not only like decent but he becomes good
at it so i saw him doing portraits one
day and i'm like man you [ __ ] suck at
drawing bro and then a month later this
fool's doing like beautiful ass
portraits of like marvel and whatever
and then he starts getting paid off of
that right wow guitar he just picked
this [ __ ] up
that's one of your portraits by the way
[ __ ] no dude while he's talking pull it
off pull it up you [ __ ] artist son of
a [ __ ] take forever to look can show
did you do that chaplin back there is
that you hold on
that's ikea okay i wanna show you a
portrait but i'll show you something i
painted but you knew that whoa
i painted this that's really good it's
kind of blurry but it's it's just like a
forest the magical forest yeah so how
big is that and then when did you get
into painting let me see [ __ ]
so he's your human heart he was doing
charcoal he was doing steve like
yeah see that's way tight that's this is
how big it is he's like the [ __ ]
thomas kincaid painter light and [ __ ]
it's a story but yeah wow
[Laughter]
hey you know what you should do you
should decorate the [ __ ] jake
officers no i'm good bro
perfect it's perfect no it's not we need
a new do you need a new office it's not
perfect it's perfect for the bathroom
okay we were talking about this
yesterday
changing the office right yeah
absolutely we got to change it up hey
bring this in hey can bring it in dude
it's in texas oh never mind don't bring
it make another one it was actually a
gift from my friend but hey ken make
some art for the office yeah please [ __ ]
okay we got bart's heart over there if
you buy if you buy a big-ass canvas i'll
just fill that [ __ ] up today's video is
brought to you by feels
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you do not feel such as stress
anxiety
pain discomfort yuck now the way i
integrate feels into my lifestyle is i
have a nighttime routine and if you have
never ever used cbd no worries feels has
an awesome little hotline that you can
call ahead and be like hey yo check this
out i've never done cbd how do i do this
and i'll walk you through the process
but this is my nighttime routine i get a
couple of drips and i go
put that in my tongue that's pretty
chill for me i do a little bit of
reading maybe some meditation some
stretching and i get off the phone and i
get ready to go to sleep and it really
helps me just have a nice eight hour
knockout session because when i'm
[ __ ] around on the phone maybe i'm
like reading emails doing whatever my
mind is like super super out there and
i'm just like full of anxiety and for
some reason i'm tossing and turning and
before you know it i'm watching three
guys in vietnam build huts in the jungle
and i can't go to sleep but thanks to
fields i have this nighttime routine and
it feels really really good and also you
can save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel at any time so start
feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com
off the record and you'll get 50
off your first order with free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com slash off the
record to become a member and get 50 off
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping fields.com
slash off the record where i got damaged
where's the [ __ ] charlie i'm going to
flip it over
just do it over it that's funny dude
just [ __ ] paint it white dude turn
into charlie periodics where is it at in
texas where huh yeah it's you said it's
in texas i was visiting my friend in
dallas and then they were having like
art night so i was like all right let me
paint you something and then boom gifted
it didn't didn't charlie chaplin like
[ __ ] a kid pretty hard yeah dude we
don't need a rep we don't need that
i thought you like headed up at some
like road house no no i don't do like a
bunch of texas guys who drew that piece
of [ __ ]
nobody gives nobody in here gives a [ __ ]
about charlie chaplin i don't even know
how that got there gives his [ __ ] dude
he made silent movies wait he was a sex
child sexual predator yeah i was just
holding a roller over that [ __ ]
really he's a child sex problem yeah bro
dude take that [ __ ] out of here dude
take that [ __ ] home let's turn him
into hitler yeah dude he looks pretty
close and then you could you could paint
over that oh right over here
turn him into a funk styles popper don't
don't paint a kid next to him
that'll be the only thing no you should
kick a hole you should get a still of
that moment with jack mcbee and the
[ __ ] older yeah dude
make a portrait of mcv i have a little
air bubble that says everyone calls me
that's my favorite part
about the clint eastwood thing yeah yeah
dude
why do you have to tell her that
everyone calls him mcbee
that is the sickest inside joke that
like the jk viewers are like really
taking it i love it oh dude yeah nobody
else is talking about it it's like a
hard thing
[Laughter]
you're so proud of them
it's ours
it's so fun to see people reference it
we're gonna copyright strike other
people's videos they start [ __ ]
talking about
because why does he need to tell her
that it's so [ __ ] great i wanna i
wanna i wanna make a football jersey
like that but it says 13 in september
dot dot dot how sick would that be dude
and the back says 12. that's so great
but 13 in september
carefully merch is gonna be on fire dude
we're gonna sell so much merch it's
crazy
dude speaking of pedophiles have you
guys heard of zoo files no
zoophiles
it's people that
basically they're animal abusers but
they [ __ ] animals oh like the freaking
uh lizard the lizard guys
oh files like ph files not like x-files
like pedophile zoo what's the difference
between a zoo file and an animality man
oh like you mean a beastiality man
beastiality yeah one is harder to pull
off what's the difference between uh
animorphs and fantastic beasts i think
because the fetish and zoophile is the
person that commits so where does furry
fall in all of this furry is also a
fetish but they just it's people cute
and acceptable yeah compared to the
animal files or whatever you can feel
them
it's kind of gross it's straight up like
animal abuse because they don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on you know so at
least furries are like doing it to each
other yeah
and it's with consent because they're
human kind of what's your uh fur [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that called the fur
uh your your personality personality
what's your first name well i'm going to
punch you in the face
my personalities i'll punch you in the
[ __ ] head right now
what is that
spirit animal's got to be different from
your personality i promise you that why
why'd you ask us that like we were
supposed to know what that is yeah what
the [ __ ] because you guys you guys don't
know what you guys know what furries are
you gotta have a person first of all
explain us explain to us what our
personality is
what animal you would be personality
okay what would what animal would you
like to me i would probably be like a
[ __ ] like snake or some [ __ ] you know
no it has to be furry you pick it you
yourself or just yeah whatever cause
yeah you get it like a queen knights you
oh yeah it's just it's just the identity
you adopt when fursuiting
okay so you could be a cat gee a box
where you're trying to put a furry
you could be
any mammal
i think i will choose
a dog i knew it i know i'm too basic bro
a chihuahua or a german shepherd lately
i've been feeling like a labrador or
like a golden retriever i'm gonna start
doing fishing moves on everybody in this
[ __ ] room he's just gonna tara
it's over the show's over
because this guy's more of a reptile
that's why do you identify as in that
community no
do you know anybody in the community
because you do have vibes that i have to
say i would not be there what kind of
vibes what kind of just a general vibe
well ever since you brought up
personality we have an eyebrow raised to
you it was the way that i think that was
the way that you asked me that question
with a straight face and just like it
was completely normal no judgment but it
seemed like you're excited captioned out
like you guys just talked about it we'll
just watch personality says here it's an
identity you adopt one for suiting what
is for suiting yeah i don't know well
you can
the fursuit of happiness ken what do you
see steve as yeah steve yeah pick one
pick one for all of us tonight
can we go birds can we do bald eagle i
was thinking
there you go good because i am losing my
hair but there's no further right no
it's because he's a [ __ ] all-american
you know has fur a wasp a white
anglo-saxon protestant has fur oh yeah
lots of do have fur and those guys [ __ ]
[ __ ] all the time
what's joe you he says dog but you pick
one for him how do you see joe as a
personality
for some reason i see you as like a
[ __ ] like goat or something
that makes sense goat is cool cause it's
like i make a lot of noise and then but
it's like they're also kind of like fun
yeah joe's a [ __ ] tasmanian devil
yeah but i can also see just joe eating
a metal can for no reason
this is true that's why it tastes good
climb canyon what about ryan ryan
definitely a teddy bear hey that's
that's cute and gay i like it
exactly
all right my turn now your turn
you
i think i know i i have one in my head i
want to see you later i think you're
just gay
got him again
like what animal is that
there's like an animorph cover i'm just
turning into himself
but it's like a different [ __ ] but
i'm just a little more fat like smirking
it's like this and then it's like
gradual change
you're like a little uh honey badger
yeah yeah yeah like a bat like a rodent
like a badger oh like a rodent cool
thanks can but like uh wolverine how
about that oh that's cool i was thinking
monkey in my head oh i like monkey i was
thinking raccoon
raccoon okay what about anthony anthony
probably something that has sex a lot
huh yeah for sure
[ __ ] a lot that [ __ ] a lot anthony is
a tiger because kenjus i appreciate that
very much wow okay he had any more like
a deer oh i could see that too like
prancing like he's like he's like
an elegant kind creature see it i see it
you sometimes get hitched
about to butt kick a dog
what's the bright light happening there
anthony is a brown and teachiness
because they [ __ ] the most in the animal
kingdom really yeah
i look up animals that have the most sex
wow what is what is that a brown i would
have assumed rabbits it's not human i
[ __ ] have no idea bro i've never
heard of it my whole life all right what
would what would bart be bart
other than like a walrus
[ __ ] that's his current season that's
his current season or like a giant bear
walrus damn like a gerbil
like a freakishly huge giant hamster i
can see that he's a hamster like a
chinchilla
no it's a hamster but big he's kind of
like a rhino or a gorilla right now oh a
rhino he's a bit of a rhino yeah i like
humans that look like animals yeah like
have you ever seen anybody that look
like a rat like their face just looked
like a rat brown and teachiness does
that look like joe these guys [ __ ] oh
that's me yeah
damn damn they [ __ ] a lot huh yeah
the most know how big is that thing they
are sexy looking they're fat they're
either not that big what about can what
you can guys yeah what's can jen's a
dead man
for looking at me like that while he
asked me
[Laughter]
as a school bully vibe oh i know what
can's a [ __ ] meerkat dog oh
yeah is
i was going to say an alpaca oh that too
dude ken's one of the most interesting
dudes to just watch sometimes because
he'll just be somewhere and he's
standing in doorway and just [ __ ]
going like this
that's what i'm saying he's like the
emperor's new groove oh yeah he is oh
that's oh that's good it's a llama right
yeah
llama that's cool i do like llamas i'm a
llama too
nice do you spit on people
see that took a turn
now